Steve what are we doing here hey Sal
we're going to look at this question of
why do empires fall and for those of you
who don't know Steve Schrader he is a
world history fellow here at Khan
Academy and also a former world history
teacher so what we want to do here is
use these big ideas these big factors
that are somewhat common across empires
to sort of understand how specific
empires fell let's start in a committed
Persia so a committed Persia it's an
empire that lasts for roughly 200 years
and I guess the obvious thing about a
committed Persia gets taken over by
Alexander the Great so I'll just go
ahead and throw invasion on that list
for a key minted Persia so outside of
invasion if we go through the rest of
this list it clearly was a large empire
so maybe there was an element of
over-expansion it was governed in a
fairly federated way through these say
traps you might have had bad leadership
be a role there's the third famous for
deserting his troops on the battlefield
yeah and on top of that we might throw
in economics as well because as
Alexander conquers bits and pieces of
the Empire he's also depriving them of
the resources that those areas would
provide so now let's move on to Moorea
India once again a significant Empire
lasts definitely over a hundred years
and it's actually the largest unified
Empire over the Indian subcontinent and
it starts with three fairly strong
rulers and it's known especially with
Ashoka the great for spreading of the
Buddhist religion so why in your mind
Steve did it fall which of these factors
played most strongly well the first one
that jumps out is over-expansion once
ashoka dies you see the empire really
lose a lot of that northwestern
territory what we did see is some
religious strife you mentioned that
Ashoka worked really hard to spread
Buddhism and he did follow that in some
of his policies which led to some
tension between some of the Hindu
population and the Empire and so you
could also call that division as well so
moving on go to Han China it began to
fall at the end of the 2nd century CE
and then falls in the third
which of these factors led to its
eventual demise right so I think we want
to start looking at the fall of Han
China from the lens of the Yellow Turban
rebellion and that is partly a religious
movement and it also is partly sparked
by environmental factors leading to food
shortages and food shortages might
affect the economy absolutely there's a
lot of internal migration to look for
better jobs within Han China because of
this you think leadership played a role
yeah there was a lot of dissatisfaction
with the Han Emperor and how he was sort
of dealing with some of these problems
and overtime efforts to defeat the
rebellion led to regional warlords
gaining more power and then they
eventually carve out their own kingdoms
from the Han domain okay
and then overlapping in time with Han
China we of course have the famous Roman
Empire and on my timeline here this
first section is a Roman Kingdom then
Roman Republic and then you have the
formal Roman Empire that collapses at
the end of the fifth century so which of
these factors you think played into
Western Roman Empire's collapse the
Byzantine Empire the each and Roman
Empire continues on for roughly a
thousand years more well let's start
with the obvious point there that there
is a division there's a formal political
division that's going to weaken both
halves of the Empire in terms of the
resources available we also have at the
same time as that division religious
issues going on
we have Christianity being declared the
official religion of the Roman Empire at
this time and that leads to internal
conflicts between those who are
Christians and those who are not you
have migrations and invasions you have
famously the Huns migrating into Eastern
Europe and then putting pressure on the
Germanic tribes to oftentimes come into
the Roman Empire but that led to so that
was both migrations and invasion yeah
and in this case it's sometimes hard to
separate invasion from migration and I
would throw in economy since the Roman
Empire and its expansionary period was
constantly getting new territory which
would add tax revenues to Rome's coffers
it allowed for more and more slaves who
could work for Rome once you get into
the third 4th century CE II that
expansion float starts to
and so it stops that ever-growing pile
of money and ever-growing pile of labor
so I'd argue economy played a role
you can never point to just one factor
empires are these very complicated
things but there are these general
themes and as a student it's valuable to
think about them in a framework
something like this
so all these factors won't apply to
every single Empire you look at they're
a good starting point when you start
thinking about those questions of why
did this particular Empire fall awesome
thanks Steve thanks Elle